make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin so we are here
time runs out probably the single
greatest avengers story that's
ever been written in the history of
marvel comics here's the thing man
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
this is when everything gets amazing
every forum post that you've ever seen
where people talk about how great
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
is
every time i've ever talked about how
great it is this is when we get to that
point so what we end up doing here
is we end up picking up in what's
basically called the alpha 1 system now
one of the things to remember is
jonathan hickman names systems based on
their sons so the alpha 1 system is just
named after its own son alpha one
but what you have here are a bunch of x
nahili now if you guys recall from the
early stories that we did
and this is why i say when it comes to
hickman's avengers and new avengers
everything builds on itself
if you guys recall in the very early
stories when we first covered this
uh with avengers world and all that
stuff ex nihilo was only one member of
his race and they had been created by
the builders for the purpose of creating
life on various worlds they're basically
representations of life right their job
is to go to different worlds
create life and if that life is you know
deemed to be something that can't
survive
or whatever the case is then an abyss
which is basically the the
representation of death destroys that
life and they kind of start over again
or something along those lines what what
they're doing here is channeling their
energy as best they can
to keep the alpha one sun alive and the
reason why is because the sun's
basically going supernova and ultimately
they fail
and 5x nahili die in the process the
result of this is that where you have ex
nihilo who's asking the question like
why did this sun go supernova why
couldn't why couldn't we save it then
you end up having the abyss right abyss
basically jumps in and says
because the sun wants to die and it's
one of the things where we're like the
other ex-nihilo who were here are like
but that doesn't make any sense right
this sun was supposed to survive for
billions of years by all standards of
measurement this son was a teenager so
why did it give up its
life and the response of of abyss is i
don't fully know
but it looks like the universe is dying
and the suns are blinking out in the
process
and so what she basically kind of
realizes here is this kind of energy
signature for lack of a better word
right her ability to
to detect the destruction of the
universe is all emanating from a
singular point
that point of course being earth because
of the nature of the incursions and so
what this does is it basically picks up
eight months later right and even this
little segment that we just covered
is about eight months later but the the
idea behind this and the reason why is
considered to be an eight months later
event is because what you end up having
or at least what marvel did here is that
when we finished the last story arc
right so like the creation of the cabal
all that kind of stuff
marvel wanted to ensure that by the time
secret wars picked up
that pretty much all the character arcs
were wrapped up right so the existing
captain america story at the time
the existing thor story by jason aaron
at the time was basically coming to an
end and so the way this works and i
don't want to be too
kind of crazy here but the way this
works is that if you go and you look at
like marvel's publication history during
this time that you
you have a you have like captain
america's comic for example it goes on
for a little bit and then you get an arc
called
the final days of captain america
basically before like right before you
get to that arc so the issue before that
arc starts
dead ends and dives but again it's one
of these things where everything's
basically dying and so what we do here
is we actually jump to the savage land
and of course you have these children
here if you guys recall those are the
children who were created when x mihilo
infected the earth and tried to try to
basically
force the earth to evolve to become a
sentient life form and that was
basically stopped right that was stopped
by star brand when he kind of killed the
sentients of the world
but these kids here were part of that
evolutionary process of ex nihilo like
kind of creating a new form of life but
talking with hyperion again eight months
have passed so you'll notice hyperion
looks a lot different than he used to
but what you also have here is advanced
idea mechanics which is now working for
robert decosta so in the last videos
that we did they were just working on
their own accord when we had like the
evil avengers and things like that they
were just doing that for their their own
purpose right trying to understand the
nature of the multiversal collapse
in their own way with robert de costa
coming along and basically now being a
source of funding and with advanced idea
mechanics working for him they now do as
they're directed and what they're trying
to do here is create a device that will
allow the avengers or at least
allow a small contingent of avengers to
enter into the multiverse right so
that's kind of what's going on there but
you end up having hyperion who travels
to meet with thor and this this right
here this is probably one of the coolest
parts of the entire story right the
friendship between thor
and hyperion these guys become gross
right it's the coolest thing because if
you guys recall hyperion was like a boy
scout he was like superman right like i
don't drink alcohol i fight the good
fight i believe in like the greatness of
people and stuff like that hyperion
because of the things that he's
experienced has become a lot more
hardened in the in the last eight months
things that we haven't really seen
taking place but has become a lot more
hardened and a lot more understanding of
how the world really is he's become very
similar to thor
becoming like a warrior now for thor
himself you guys will notice he doesn't
have his hammer and he's got a metal arm
the reason for that takes place in jason
aaron's thor run right that's that's one
of the things that jonathan hickman did
was taking the information from that
comic and rolling it over into here to
make this really quick and you guys are
welcome to check it out if you want to
in the thor run
uh thor basically lost the ability to
wield his hammer and lost his uh lost
you know his arm in the the first arc
where jane foster took over
and became the new thor that's why he's
wielding his battle axe he's not worthy
to lift his own hammer and so it's a
cool little moment here because from
there
it switches over to uh to basically
golgotha which is essentially like a
shield station which is previously
avengers tower so the avengers have been
ran
out of their own facility and has been
completely and totally taken over by
shield now you've got maria hill who's
talking to someone the simply archangel
command right so she's reporting to
somebody else but basically maria hill
kind of gives a field
response and saying like here's what's
going on where we're out here right now
right so hey boss
here's what we found it's basically what
she says and what we end up finding out
is they've discovered that amadeus cho
is trying to hack into avengers mansion
now amadeus cho is a character that's
relatively new at the time this story
was published but he's a guy who was
super intelligent one of the big issues
with amadeus cho
is that there wasn't a whole lot of
expansion to his character insofar as
like building him up and making him
wildly interesting but basically he's a
guy that has the ability to basically be
in any situation
and analyze it using mathematical
probability and then find a way out
right to basically figure out the best
possible way for him to escape any
situation that he's in and as soon as
the alarms go off which he expected to
happen he reports to somebody else and
he tells somebody else yeah i'm
in but the alarm's activated and he's
told get out now shield
immediately leaps in and you've got
their their shield agents who come
running in and you've got amadeus cho
calculating all these mathematical
probabilities in his head right he's one
of the eight smartest people in the
world he's calculating all these
probabilities in his head he's met by
war machine
he's met by carol danvers and he's met
by hawkeye and he immediately
gets the upper hand over all three of
them right he manages to take out war
machine he ends up friendly firing onto
uh carol danvers and then hawkeye has to
dodge out of the way when friendly fire
is set upon him right so it's taking
over the iron man armor which is no
small thing and so what that does
is it gives him a chance to kind of get
away this leads to other war machine
armors flying in and trying to take out
amadeus cho
the whole time he's calculating
mathematical probabilities right the
whole time he's calculating a way out
until he gets to a point where he can't
teleport away
right he can't escape and instead the
device is implanted into his hand
that the illuminati used to basically
allow them to teleport to different
locations is removed and it's destroyed
so right off the bat we know amadeus cho
is working with the illuminati and he's
the you know they're the ones that he
was reporting to
from there it goes into a series of
questions that are being asked where's
iron man now you guys will notice
this is superior iron man the way this
looks that's one of the things that took
place
during this eight month window and so
for a lot of people who were who read
the events of superior iron man and then
it just
ends that's because of the fact that it
ends and goes into this eight months
later time period so this is what tony
stark was doing
after the events of superior iron man
but the other question is asked where is
hulk where's ant-man where's captain
britain where is doctor strange this is
a lot of the stuff that's been going on
in the last eight months in the last
eight months captain britain's joined
the illuminati ant-man joined the
illuminati although we're gonna find out
a lot more about him than we knew before
that's the other thing where's black
bull where is black panther where's
beast right
where is reed richards we find out this
question is being asked by susan storm
she says where is my husband she's cited
against reed richards and the fantastic
four now the reason for this comes by
way of the fact that in the last story
arc that we covered with regards to the
avengers captain america figured out
what was going on with the incursions he
remembered he remembered everything that
was going on what he did is he went to
the avengers and told them what was
happening basically said here's
everything that i know
this led to a sort of split among the
avengers team that some individuals
believed captain america because of the
fact that
he's captain america he doesn't have a
reason to lie other people thought that
maybe he was losing his mind rather
maybe there was something else going on
and they sided against him or they
believed that what the illuminati were
doing was right and that basically led
to sort of a rift and so ultimately you
ended up having susan storm
siding with this whole cause and it
seems as though she's the one reporting
to captain america
and so from there we switch over to
latviria and what you end up having is
neymar the submariner talking to doctor
doom and we find out that in the last
video that we did that namor had created
the cabal right thanos and the
the black order and so on and their job
was to basically
you know destroy worlds that were
incursing onto earth right to basically
keep the main marvel universe as safe as
they could by doing what the illuminati
could not do
be willing to destroy a world the
problem with this is that where the the
black order signed on and said
yeah like we're definitely down for this
right to like keep our universe intact
to keep the universe from being
destroyed what's happened
is that over the course of these eight
months the black order has become
bloodlusted right they take relish and
not necessarily
not only just destroying those worlds
but they take they take relish and
comfort and actually killing the
superheroes to them it's not even about
protecting the universe anymore it's
about just inflicting as much death and
destruction as they possibly can
and so of course they also bring the
anti-matter bombs and they destroy those
in cursive earth and that's the concern
that namor has
right that like it's not the way it's
supposed to be this is supposed to be a
group
doing what they need to do this is not
supposed to be a group doing what they
love to do and that's when he basically
goes to dr doom and says i need your
help in trying to keep this contained
and the response of doom is
no and and where name was like why like
why wouldn't you help me with this dr
noon basically says
if you believed that the illuminati
weren't able to do what they needed to
do in order to keep the incursions from
happening then you could have come to me
before you threw in with people like
thanos and his black order you could
have come to me like you could have come
to me we could have talked and we could
have found a way to make it work do i
strike you as the kind of person who
would have said no to that right there's
there's this really great line that
doctor doom delivers where he's talking
to name with a submariner and they're
talking about what it means to be kings
and he says i love my people like i do
but they are my people i keep them safe
from harm i give them a better life and
at night before they pray to whatever
god they believe in
they give thanks to me yes like i am an
absolute ruler over this place but i
don't rule as a dictator i rule as a
just and peaceful king and he tells
namor you threw in your lot with the
wrong people
and now you're dragging the stinking
carcass of your failure to my front door
hoping that i'll somehow bail you out no
you're on your own
get out of here like it's the coolest
thing this is why doctor doom is so
awesome one because he delivers some of
the best lines
right like he delivers like amazing
lines but two he's a guy that basically
is very very prideful right because at
the end of the day
he really just sort of breaks it down
and says like doctor doom is nobody's
second choice so like at the end of the
day he's just pissed that he wasn't the
first choice of name or the submariner
but the other thing about this is doctor
doom actually has a backup plan but
before we find out what it is we end up
picking up in an alternate reality
designated earth 71-202 and you end up
picking up with corvus glaive right and
he's basically taunting charles xavier
after having killed the x-men
and they asked he asked the question
like i look around and i wonder where is
zorn
this guy who hid the sun behind his mask
where's his brother who hit a black hole
behind his mask
where are your x-men charles xavier
where are your champions where are your
heroes and the response of xavier is i
don't know and and and literally corvus
slave is like i know
i know because when we arrived on this
wretched backwater world
you sent them here to kill us what i
want to present you here is a final word
from your champions from your
from the from the champion of zorn and
his brother zorn and then it switches
over
to terex the tamer and it's this amazing
thing right this amazing monologue where
it's like what was the purpose in what
we did right
where is the virtue in dying for a
useless cause right was it enough
that we proved our bravery by flying
into a conflict that we couldn't win
at your request because you
underestimated the forces that we are
facing off against
we died for no reason at all are you
finally proud of us
are you finally proud of the fact that
we gave our lives for your great cause
but at the end of the day we deserved
better we deserve better than a fate of
dying
against forces we couldn't possibly hope
to have defeated in the first place
and then they kiss
[Laughter]
i love that lie and the response of
xavier is like you're crazy
all of you guys are crazy what's wrong
with all of you and then the response of
corvus glaive is
look over there human look at this man
thanos this being this monstrosity of a
form this force
that manhandled every single one of your
x-men
and crushed them with the greatest of
ease look upon the face of death this
force but you could have never had
any chance of stopping in the first
place and when xavier asks
what do you want the response of corvus
glaive is very little
professor x a pittance a portion a
tribute and that's the coolest thing
because that was our introduction to
corvus glaive if you remember the events
of infinity when he showed up on that
world and basically said i want all your
children's heads right that
it was it was pretty intense and when
xavier asks what is it
thanos says i want you to beg i want you
to beg me to kill you and where xavier
is like like
no that's not going to happen and you
end up having terraxitamer who chimes in
and says but like we know you will
though your x-men are gone there's
really nothing left here but we do have
a couple of them we have a couple of
your x-men here and we we can save them
we can keep them alive right we won't
execute them in front of you but only
if you beg and because xavier cares so
much about his x-men
he ends up begging and thanos takes
comfort in it
takes relish in in in professor x
begging for his life from there
we switch to the fallen city of wakanda
right wakanda has basically been been
collapsed and it's been conquered now
when the black order escaped they laid
ruined to it all right they obliterated
almost the entirety of wakanda but what
what they left behind were drones these
drones are tasked with cruising through
the city and eliminating anybody that
they find right and what you end up
having
is a group that basically makes its way
into wakanda itself which are basically
like the dogs of war right the wakandan
dogs of war it's the coolest concept
because you have black panther i guess
t'challa and you have a sister shuri who
get in there and the reason why they're
here is because they're basically
accessing where all of the anti-matter
bombs are right if you guys remember
that the illuminati created them for the
purpose of destroying worlds the black
panther and his crew were sneaking in
here to get them away right to ensure
that cabal cannot continue doing what
they're doing because the illuminati
knows what's going on right
so now is the illuminati trying to stop
the cabal from doing what the illuminati
we're ultimately probably gonna have to
do anyway it's just the cabal is so
extreme they're just so rampant just
hopping across entire universes and
wiping out entire earths right just
killing everything out of a bloodlust
and so you end up having one of the dogs
of war who steps up to this to the
antimatter bombs and is immediately
incinerated and then you're met with the
arrival of maximus the mad right he's
the one that basically freed the black
order and it's kind of one of these
these funny things because where
t'challa says
you don't really believe i can't get
past this force field i'm like the third
smartest person in the world the
response of maximus is no i mean
you know you probably could but
understand you're locked in here
like you're you're locked in here and
you're you're gonna face off against
proxima midnight now approximately
midnight this is kind of the cool thing
she is a hoss right like she's a demon
like a one-on-one confrontation she's
very very difficult for people to take
out really a couple of the wakandans are
taken out and then you end up having one
of the dogs of war who tells t'challa
and shuri get out of here right like get
out of here and run and they basically
end up fleeing and he makes this amazing
this amazing line right he says like
look here woman i am a hot toot
zarazi a dog of war i was made to die
for my country have you ever seen such
conviction
and then pulls the pen and and like
literally blows up and approximate
midnight's like every day that i wake i
have more conviction than you could
possibly ever imagine
she of course survives the explosion and
then ends up tracking down black panther
and shuri and what you end up having is
black panther basically telling the
telling the illuminati the mission
failed we couldn't get a hold of the
anti-matter bombs there was a force
field up we were ambushed by proxima
midnight we had to get out of there as
fast as we can
the responsive read is let's get out of
here and he tells shuri we have to go
and she says
i'm not coming we fight for something
like the idea is that we
fight for wakanda we fight for our city
if i'm going to die
i'm going to die as the black panther of
my city i will not die anywhere else you
have a bigger mission here you have a
bigger role to play here
go and join the illuminati she's not
taking this from a stance of anger you
know she doesn't look at him as somebody
who's abandoning their place
no not at all and so you basically end
up having t'challa who says okay then i
will undertake my mission shuri ends up
staying behind and so you end up having
approximate midnight who shows up here
it's like
the coolest moment right like man let me
tell you something it's the coolest
moment proxima midnight shows up here
and she was like oh
man like black panther like he abandoned
you like man that's that's
wild like what are you gonna do because
like you're gonna die and she asked like
do you know
what i see right now and shuri's like
what do you see and she's like i see
nothing that breathes tomorrow so i'm
going to give you an option
either you can see this death coming or
you can be a coward and you can turn
around
sure he leaps up right into the battle
switch
we don't get to see what happens instead
we pick up with doctor doom right and
he's asked by christoph
by his son christopher bernard after
neymar leaves and he's like do you
really believe it was a smart idea to
like not take neymar on as an
ally and the response of doom is no
because he's a broken version of himself
he's no king he's not the person that he
used to be above
all else the only thing that we really
have in this world
is loyalty to who we are as soon as we
lose who it is that we are
we have nothing else we're just a shell
of our former selves we're no longer
kings we're no longer rulers right you
don't have to be
uh be in charge of a kingdom to truly be
a king you just have to know who you are
and understand that that's not something
that you're willing to sacrifice besides
it's not really the biggest deal in the
world
they end up opening the store and we end
up finding out the thinkers here right
now the mad thinker is an old fantastic
four villain he would create these
little like little robots things like
that to face off against the fantastic
four he's more or less like a 60s
villain like a 60s and 70s villain he
was peanuts right he was very he was
very very very small time but he is
exceedingly intelligent and if you guys
recall in one of the previous videos
that we did we talked about how the
first incursion that happened that the
illuminati coped with where we saw the
map makers that a piece of that earth or
piece of that that alternate reality
earth ended up landing in latviria and
dr doom got his hands on it and what
he's been doing is
analyzing it this entire time now if you
guys recall the nature of the map makers
right the nature of these these cedar
and maoris is that when they land on an
alternate earth that they bring a piece
of that earth with them and what that
piece of the earth does is it literally
sends out a homing beacon and it says
hey guys come here and the map makers
follow that signal and then they arrive
on the new earth they lay waste to any
kind of life on that earth they destroy
it and then they move on to the next one
right like that's how that process works
well with this piece being here and with
it sending out a kind of signal what the
mad finger's been doing is
analyzing it and what he ends up
realizing is that this signal is
actually part of a network right just so
it's like your computer hooking up to
the internet it's sending out a signal
constantly and if you can crack the
signal you can trace the signal and you
can see what this signal is
communicating with and you can see what
that signal's communicating with
and so on and so forth and ultimately
end up tracing and really mapping the
entirety of the multiversal network and
so what this means is dr doom now knows
everywhere the map makers have been
which means he can trace them to their
source he can find out
where they originally came from he can
basically locate the ivory kings right
the white lords of wild space and when
the question's asked
like what plan do we have here the
response of doctor doom is i have
everything i need i've got my plan i
know exactly what i have to do to
implement the plan
and i have the source of power that can
help me achieve this plan i have
the molecule man owen reese let there be
suffering and woe to all who stand in my
way and that's the reality of it
molecule man is a multiversal powerful
character with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you